Hello.
Good morning, everybody.
Whoa.
Good morning.
I am... I thought 12 p.m.
12.30 p.m.
was bad.
But then... But then I found out there is an even harder time slot.
And it's 12... And it's 10 in the morning.
Now you guys might be wondering... Like... Oh, hey.
Hey, Tokyo.
Come on.
Get on.
Get on the game.
Weren't you on the game yet?
Because they did say... At 10 a.m.
At 10 a.m.
there's apparently a population cap.
Which is fucking crazy.
Because... I thought... I thought... People who have access to this game... Are mostly just creators.
And... Oh, wait.
I'm in.
Never mind.
Ha-ha.
JK.
I take back everything I just said.
I... I'm in.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
I take it all back.
Um... But... The issue right now... Is that... I can't click... Accept.
Wait.
Why is my mouse not working... On this game?
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Wait a minute.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, did my game?
No way.
There's no fucking way.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
I can't move my mouse.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha Why can't I move my mouse when I'm tapped into the game?
Like, what?
Why can't I move my mouse?
That's so weird.
Okay, guys, we're gonna wait even longer.
Oh, this sucks because there is a population cap.
So, like, this is gonna be so...
Oh, wait.
Like, what?
Is it because it's on DX12?
Oh, my God.
Guys, all right, guys.
We're gonna have to wait even longer, apparently.
Because we might have got in, but we're not in.
We're not in anymore.
So, there's a population.
This releases a little scuff, not gonna lie.
Is it cloud test?
It must be.
I can't... I literally can't move my... Oh, man.
I have to wait.
I have to wait even more.
Because I... I, like, booted up, man.
Oh, my God.
It's, like, actually fucking up my PC right now.
Oh, man.
Oh, fuck.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I can't even...
I can't task, man.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, my God.
As you... No, it's not.
The game literally launches at 10.
Like, I can't do anything about it.
Um, they launch at exactly 10 a.m.
So, I can't test it out at all.
There's... There's no way to test it out.
Because, um, it launches at that time.
Uh...
And they put a population cap, too.
So, like... Oh, no.
Not to...
I'm scared.
I'm scared, like, I have to wait even longer.
Because, um...
I got on exactly at 10.
And...
And I'm really scared that...
Uh...
I'm really scared that we have to wait even longer.
I thought...
No, it's because, like, um...
I have to force quit the game.
I'm... I have to force quit the game there.
So, because I have to force quit...
Uh... Oh, thank God.
Oh...
No, not thank God.
Okay, never mind.
Never mind!
Not thank God!
Okay, we're back on that screen.
We're back on it.
Okay.
Um...
Wait, why is it not...
At least...
Let me show you the screen.
Alright, so...
It might take a while...
For us to get in.
Because, like I said...
Um...
Uh...
Like I said...
Um...
I was on it...
At exactly 10am.
And now it's not...
You know...
Now...
Now I might not be in it.
Now I might not be in the queue anymore.
So...
That's the problem.
I'm not...
Because they have a queue system...
For everything.
Um...
They have a queue system.
And I join the queue at exactly 10 in the morning.
Which is when they open the doors.
And...
Uh...
I couldn't move my mouse...
When they put me in.
Because I have to accept the TOS.
And then when I accepted the TOS...
I tried to accept the TOS.
But it wouldn't let me move my mouse.
Which is...
Fucking weird.
I think I just can't tab out.
I think this game doesn't let me tab out.
Which is crazy.
Because I...
Oh my god.
Okay.
This...
Wait!
I'm in!
Am I in?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm in.
I might have to force quit my game again.
HAHAHAHAHAHA!!!
Okay.
Every...
I'm gonna say it.
But like...
It's very awkward.
Because you know.
We went through the nice relaxing...
Like the last time we were in the early access game.
It was nice and relaxing.
Um...
Because like...
Wait.
Why is it just a black screen?
I...
Because it was Marble Rivals.
And the launch for Marble Rivals was incredibly smooth.
So I'm not used to... Oh, man.
Here we go.
Alright.
Yay, we're in!
This is a rollercoaster of emotions right there.
I feel like I'm so back and then I'm not back.
I thought this was just for streamers only, but I forgot they gave access to, like, some other...
Some, like, they gave access to, like, non-creators, too.
Because, like, there was, like, a lottery system for it.
So I was like, how is there a population cap when it's just creators?
But I forgot.
There are non-creators in this server.
I have no idea what this game is about other than the fact that it's an extraction shooter and people were mad.
They were, like...
Like, when it was first announced, people were excited.
And then, like, I think, like, a couple of weeks ago, they were, like, Oh, it's an extraction shooter and then people got mad.
And then when I... I didn't realize that people were already hating this game.
When I tweeted... When I tweeted at Waiter Room, I saw so many people putting, like...
Um, you're gonna need a drink about this.
I can't believe you're playing this trash.
I was like, whoa.
I didn't realize people hate this game already.
I literally just got a free alpha code.
Like, hey, guys.
Hey, look.
I'm just checking out a new game.
Look, Shroud's playing it, okay?
Like, all the big streamers are playing this game right now.
Don't play me, guys.
All... All the...
Every big streamer who's anybody is currently playing this game.
Like, every FPS streamer right now.
Even Lyric is on it.
I'm just surprised Lyric is playing this game.
Um...
People were so mad.
I was just like, I could...
I am just trying...
I'm just checking out a new game, guys.
I'm just checking it out.
I didn't know this game was already so hated.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Um...
Skellum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Okay, so these are all the characters.
Oh, wait.
You guys can't...
Sorry.
It's...
I forgot my screen share is pretty fucky right now.
Uh...
Let me fix the screen share.
Because I have to use, like...
I have to use...
Um...
Let me fix the screen share real quick.
Because the reason why it's, like, super fuck...
I just realized it was super zoomed in.
So if it looked really weird there...
It's because it was super zoomed in.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Uh...
Because I have to use...
I can't use game capture.
I have to use, like, window capture.
Which is, um...
Not a capture I prefer to use.
Um...
It's not like it's desktop capture.
It's just a different...
It's just...
I think this game used to be run by admin for game capture.
Um...
Anyway, so...
Locust War...
Oh, is it because...
This is, like, a remaster, right?
Or, like, a remake of the original Marathon game.
Or a sequel.
I don't know.
Apparently...
The original game was Marathon.
And I guess that's why people were mad.
Because the original Marathon game was, um...
The original Marathon game, um...
Was non-extraction shooter.
So...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha...
Uh...
It's a reimagining.
Okay, yeah.
So I guess that's why people got mad.
Because I assume the original Marathon was non-extraction.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
Um...
Yeah, alright.
Locust.
War is brutal.
Be brutal.
Brothers are nature.
Okay.
Combat break the rhythm.
Camp...
Combat anarchist.
Combat specialist.
Uh...
Tactical strategist.
Run.
See the pattern.
Become the pattern.
Run.
Die.
Repeat.
Run.
Deliver the signal.
Oh my god.
I'm already lagging.
Okay.
I need to fix my...
I'm like in the character select.
I don't...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I don't know.
Where's the options?
Okay.
Uh...
Settings.
All right.
Let's...
Let's fix the settings real quick.
Um...
All right.
Let's turn down the cents.
I'll put it at 13 for now, and I'll figure this out later.
This is bad because there's no aim converter right now for Marathon, and I don't know the calculations to do this.
Hold Quick Melee.
Let's fix all my settings now.
Toggle Zoom.
We don't use toggle.
We use Hold Sprint.
Toggle Sprint.
I'd rather use Hold Sprint.
Uh... Oops.
Alright.
Uh...
Let's see...
I wanna get rid of... How do I...
How do I get rid of this?
I don't want this.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's not good.
Wait, I can't have that.
How do I...
What?
How do I... I'm just gonna put this on caps lock.
Who cares?
Okay, toggle crouch.
How do I...
Get rid of it?
Like, hello?
How do I...
Get rid of it?
Alright, I guess we don't get rid of it.
I don't know how to get rid of things.
It won't let me...
It won't let me get rid of it, too.
Oh, that's awkward.
You don't.
No, if I right-click, it goes to... Wait, can I right-click it?
Okay, let's see.
Like, it doesn't explain to me how to get rid of it, so I'm, like, confused.
Nope, it doesn't get rid of it.
Alright, that's awkward.
Yeah, let's cap that.
Um, we'll do 244, since that's where my monitor's at.
244, anti-alias.
Uh, okay.
I need to put this down.
I do not need to play at the highs.
We... Wait, since it's an extraction shooter... Uh, let's just put it on high for now.
And, like, let's stress test this.
We'll put it on high and stress test all of this.
Put this off.
I feel like if it's a shooter, just have motion blur off automatically.
I don't know why people would put that.
I feel like if you're from the shooter, you play FPS games, and you're an FPS dev, you just put motion blur on default in general.
Um, I think that you should know that it should be, um...
It should be, like, off the auto... like, on default, just because people normally don't play with it on.
Uh, subtitles are always on.
Why is it extra small?
I'm fucking blind as hell.
I...
That does not make sense.
Why you would have...
Why the fuck was that on extra small?
Alright.
Gameplay.
Let me double check.
Okay.
Socials.
Crew invites.
Voice chat.
Push to talk.
Please put it on.
Uh, I do not want to...
Why the fuck was push to talk on off default?
Oh, my God!
I would have been...
If I queued up, I would have been open mic.
That would have been embarrassing.
Um.
Alright, let's...
Where's the push to talk button?
Where is it?
Did you know push to talk button?
What the fuck?
Where is it?
Move...
Oh, there it is.
Push to talk.
Okay, here we go.
Um...
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
They don't have proximity chat.
Well, I still have to talk to people in my own team.
Like...
People in my...
I...
People in my own team would have heard me talk.
Because you have to be in, like, a squad of three.
Always?
Or something?
Uh...
Oh, wait.
No, it's a solo game.
Never mind.
I thought...
Okay, so for those who don't know.
When you get...
If you get a creator code.
They give you...
Two friend codes as well.
I assume the squad up.
But, like...
It's solo only.
Oh, maybe...
Oh, it's training!
Oh, that's why.
Okay.
It's a game mode.
So, yeah.
I was gonna say...
Like...
That's awkward if...
Oh, my God.
There you go.
There's my extraction shooter.
Uh...
There it is.
Um...
So, a lot of streamers are going in with three already.
And so...
Uh...
That's why, like...
I was, like, thinking, like...
Okay.
You have to play with three people in general.
Even if it's randoms.
Um...
Okay.
How the fuck do I start this?
Run.
I think it's alpha axis, guys.
If you guys...
Okay.
I won't judge the UI.
Because it is in alpha...
Axis.
It's not even in beta axis.
So, um...
I'm not surprised that...
The UI might look a little bit fucking wonky.
It looks like it's not finished.
Because I assume that...
Because it is in alpha.
But if it doesn't change in beta...
Then I'm like...
Oh, this is how it's gonna be.
Uh...
If...
If it doesn't change in the beta...
Then I'll be like...
Okay.
That's...
That's how it's gonna look like, I guess.
Alright.
I'm just not used to like...
I don't know.
I'm gonna say the launch was not as smooth as it...
Even getting like...
Alpha axis was like...
Really frustrating.
It was like...
Very frustrating in general.
Alright.
Um...
I hope this is all alpha.
Also, sound guy.
Let me know if everything's okay.
Okay.
That's me.
I hope outside is axis.
I hope outside is alpha axis.
Because that looks like shit.
Not gonna lie.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
I have a shield.
Okay.
Select your patch kit...
And use it to repair your shell.
Oh, am I...
Not okay?
I'm not okay.
Get me on.
Yeah.
Alright.
Nice.
Use it to regenerate damaged shields.
Alright.
I'm plugging it in.
Plugged.
I'm allowed outside now.
This has been disrupted.
Search the containers in the next room for armaments, ammunition.
Alright.
Here's the extraction part.
Why do I...
Put it over faster?
Put it over faster.
There you go.
Alright.
Get me some...
Substation key.
Controls...
The fuck?
Controls doorway within...
The subsection.
But how do I...
How do I get equipment faster?
Like, that's the struggle for me right now.
Oh, man.
I hope this is just alpha.
All I'm saying is that...
This doesn't look...
I'm on high...
Highest graphics just to see what it looks like.
Yeah, it looks a little Robloxy.
Not gonna lie.
I will admit...
This does look a little Robloxy.
Alright.
This is just a tutorial.
Maybe it's just a tutorial area.
Oops.
How much bullets do I have?
Okay.
Enough.
I have a lot of bullets.
Alright.
Let's see.
Like...
Why is it like that?
I wanna...
Is there a way...
Easier way to...
Let's see.
I'm trying to see if there's like fast way...
No.
What?
There isn't?
Do I just...
Is there an easier way to fucking grab my items?
Like...
That's all I wanna know.
Is there an easier way?
Okay.
What is that?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
I got it.
Oh, I'm outside now.
I thought I would never have to go outside.
Oh, just left click it?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Where?
Engage or evade the enemy as you move towards your exit.
Where is it?
Thankfully, your shell is equipped with powerful abilities.
Deploy them to give yourself an edge in a firefight.
Oh, right here.
That's fine.
I don't want to hold my shield anyway.
How do I...
I'm trying to...
Oh, there you go.
It's two.
Okay.
Wait.
I hear an enemy.
Reach the exfilt point and activate the device to escape the planet with everything you can.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Exfiltration within the time unit will result in the loss of everything you can.
Oh, there's...
And the death of your shell.
There's recoil.
Jesus Christ.
There is actual recoil you have to control.
What?
How did I do that?
Oh, it's just jump.
Double jump.
Okay.
I'm, like, trying to figure out this control...
The thing I'm not really too happy about is the stamina.
Okay.
You just have to, like, left-click it.
You've reached the exfilt point.
Activate it to initiate the matter transfer and transport yourself and your possessions to safety.
Alright.
Once the transfer begins, stay within the active area.
There is movement, yeah.
There is recoil.
I'll show you guys the recoil here.
That's me not holding...
Like, that's me just not controlling...
Um...
Yeah, there...
That's me not controlling it.
That's the recoil.
I mean...
I think, like, my only issue is that it does look Roblox-y outside.
Which, like...
It could be just the style, but...
Um...
I'm not really into that type of style for my, uh...
Gun gameplay.
Stamina is, like...
I'm not used to, like...
Stam...
I have a good stamina control.
Because I'm not used to controlling my stamina management.
Yeah.
Alright.
Return to lobby.
That was my tutorial.
That was a very fast tutorial.
I...
They teach me more.
But I guess now I go in and I hope I don't get yelled at by other creators.
Alright.
That's it.
What's this?
Oh, it's shader issue.
Shader code is not finished.
Okay.
What's this?
This is lore?
Is YouTube lagging like crazy?
Let me check.
Oh, it does say...
Oh, nope.
Seems fine.
I actually don't know.
Oh, it's good?
Okay.
It could be YouTube then.
Then, if some people aren't lagging.
Oh, if some people are stuttering a little.
It could be YouTube.
I actually don't know.
It could be YouTube then.
Then, if some people aren't experiencing it.
Alright.
So, I guess she's the lore giver.
Is that it?
Did she give me the lore?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, okay.
She's giving...
Oh, she's like the quest giver.
I see.
I am not a fan of the UI.
I'm so overwhelmed.
I...
I'm actually...
I'm a little overwhelmed with...
Okay.
With this UI.
I...
I'm gonna assume it's just alpha.
But I'm not...
I am very overwhelmed looking at this UI.
Digital contracts can be found.
Purely populates with new standards.
If you select it, it does not fit your place out.
You can re-roll it.
Standard contracts are simple.
Repeal tasks are more focused and offered increased rewards.
Jesus Christ, this font.
Oh, fuck.
Did I...
Activate it, I guess.
I...
Oh, shit.
Like...
I'm...
I am...
I am so...
Out of...
I'm so overwhelmed right now.
I'm not okay.
Okay.
I clicked the thing.
Alright.
Okay.
Get me out, I guess.
I activated it.
Welcome to the Marathon's closed alpha.
Okay.
That's cool.
Uh...
There's perimeter and there's...
I guess we'll try perimeter because I...
This is the...
The first one.
Fuck.
Okay.
Let's see.
What are the other abilities?
Search and destroy.
Barricade.
What the fuck is disruptor?
Transform your aim into a cannon?
Wait.
That sounds so fucking cool.
Oh, wait.
There's different...
To fire boosters to...
Oh!
When I did the double jump, it's different.
Double press sprint to move faster at a cost of generating increasing heat.
Activate your shoulder mounted missile pods.
Oh, I didn't even realize I have a missile pod.
Uh...
Reducing increases movement speed and weapon dexterity.
Activate...
Inand to perform another jump.
Grants a supercharged slide.
Okay.
That's like...
The heat I assume is stamina.
Also, I'm lagging because for some reason, during character select, I lag.
Like, I...
I don't understand.
It's only...
I feel like it's only in the character select that this happens, too.
Okay.
To gently...
Alright, what's this?
Activate your shell through releasing series of sonar pulses that reveals the location.
Deploy a micro bot that tracks down nearby hostiles.
Ooh, I like that.
Um...
Yawmish, they're ruining in your shell's HUD.
Performing a finisher on a runner pings their crew.
Uh...
They leave behind a lingerie.
Okay, so this is the support.
Blackbird is...
Alright, we're never using any smoke characters because that would just be...
I'll try it.
Blackbird.
That should be...
Let's go.
Alright.
Let's see who...
Crew fill enable if empty.
Oh, nice.
Let's grab...
Grab people in and hope we don't get...
Yelled at.
Let's...
Let's just hope we don't get yelled at, guys.
So I did get two free friend codes for...
Like...
For being created.
And...
You can see that I'm playing alone.
So I didn't bring anyone with me.
Um...
No, there is.
There is.
There's just no...
Proximity.
I...
Apparently, there's just no proximity VC.
But there is regular VC.
Um...
There is, like, team VC.
I'm pretty sure there's team voice chat.
It's just that you can't talk to, like, uh...
Enemies.
Um...
But yeah, I'm a little worried that...
I mean, I could do no fill, but we'll see what...
If, like, the experience with playing with randoms is not the best, I'll just play with...
I'll just play with, like, no fill and just get absolute shit on because I think all the other bigger creators brought friends.
But I'm pretty sure there's just, like, you guys just can't talk to, like, the enemies, but you can talk to your own team because I had the option to.
I had the, like, settings to talk to, like, my own teammates.
So, unless they, like, turn it off during alpha, which would be fucking weird to do.
So, I hope they didn't, like, I'll still get water.
I'll be right back, guys.
Oh, shit.
No, my headphones!
Sorry, I dropped accidentally.
My foot got caught on the wire of my headphones, so I fell.
Alright.
So, my headphones are okay.
So, I didn't hook that up.
Wow, that standby is taking a while.
I'll assume it's because we need...
I didn't start right away, so...
I only assume I didn't start right away.
So, now they're, like, waiting for it to fill up the lobby.
That's my bad.
I should have maybe stopped, started the game right away.
I just assumed that...
I don't know.
I just thought I would find a lot.
I thought, like, since an extraction shooter, I get in, like...
Um...
I'd get in, like...
Faster?
But I guess that's when you find...
Oh, maybe no one else needed a team.
Oh, you're right.
Wait, can I cancel?
Am I, like, the one only solo?
Manny and Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I should have said it solo.
But I can't get out.
Oh, this is bad.
I...
I'm stuck here.
Trying to find other...
Players.
Please.
Any others...
Did all the other creators have friends?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
How did the other creators have friends already?
I...
Please.
That's not fair.
I should have...
Why did I not bring anyone here?
No, that's so funny.
Please.
All right, guys.
If we don't get a game in...
Um...
If we don't get a game within, like...
Uh...
Five minutes...
Oh, wait.
We might have to reboot the game so I can...
Play...
I have to do solo queue.
No!
I don't understand.
I thought there'd be people who are friendless too!
What do you mean?
There's randoms in here?
There's non-creators in this lobby?
All right.
That's not fair.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe other creators have friends.
I...
It's not fair.
How was I supposed to know?
I thought...
I'd get in...
Right away.
I can't believe I'm forced to, like...
Actually solo queue.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
I just want to know what it's like.
How dare they.
Do people still solo queue?
Apparently not.
Apparently I am, like...
The world's only solo queueer in this marathon alpha.
Oh, I'm in!
Your gear is at risk.
You will lose all equipped gear if you exit or disconnect from the game.
Guys, thank god I didn't disconnect.
I hope I don't get yelled at.
Okay.
Now what?
Oh.
I have no idea who these people are.
But here I am.
Oh my god.
I am not the world's only solo queueer.
But I am la...
Wait, am I...
Let's see.
Um...
Oh no.
I'm not lagging.
It was just when we were paused.
Alright.
Hello, everybody.
I'm not gonna talk to them.
Do I have an actual gun?
I do.
Okay.
Is there fall damage?
Oh, no fall damage.
That's the best part.
Alright.
Let's see.
Will I get shot at?
If I, like, go in by myself?
Let's find out.
Okay.
I love extraction shooters.
I hope it lives longer than two months.
Alright.
Well...
Um...
Cool.
Well, I guess I'll get the scraps.
That's cool.
Wait, what?
Oh, there's, like, stuff over here.
We're solo queuing.
We are not...
We're definitely not playing as if...
I don't know.
Okay, there is health.
And shield charge.
We might need that.
Definitely.
Okay, nice.
I can just break windows.
Oh, wait.
Somebody...
Someone's injured.
Oh, people are fighting already.
Where are they?
Okay.
Oh, that's just AI.
There we go.
It's just AI.
Nothing to worry about.
All right.
Whoops.
Go.
I don't know what that...
I forgot what it does.
But go.
Go do your thing.
Go!
Travel!
Find somebody!
I don't think you found anyone.
What's this?
Wait, what the fuck?
What am I getting shot at?
Let me, like, get recharge.
Shield recharge.
Wait, what?
How are you down?
I don't know this map to, like, fucking save you.
Where are you?
Who killed you?
Oh, shit!
Who the fuck killed you?
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
Did you die to an AI?
Bro.
That's awkward.
What?
What the fuck does that mean?
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh.
Wait, there's people near me.
I hear them.
I don't remember some of my abilities.
I'm a little confused.
I think he died to AI.
Because, like, we would have been pushed instantly if it was a real person.
And we weren't.
So I'm pretty sure he just died to AI.
Like, right now.
Bro!
Bro, I can tell you don't play shooters normally.
Like, I can sort of tell that this guy does not normally play shooters.
How he plays?
Yeah.
Oh, man.
Let me...
I can only use my pistol.
I don't have a lot of ammo left.
Okay.
Bro, are you really gonna take my shit?
I killed him for us.
Yeah, I don't have much ammo now.
I have to be careful.
I literally wasted all my ammo for this one guy.
God, where's the ammo here?
I'm just taking shit just to take shit.
Does anyone remember what my spacebar thing was?
Wait, what?
Reinforcements are incoming.
I definitely need ammo, though.
I need lock container key.
Alright.
Well, now we know that things are breakable.
I can't shoot much.
I don't have a lot of ammo.
I hope that he's gonna help us.
Alright.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Smoke grenade.
Mechanics hit.
What do I have here?
I don't know.
That affects.
Immobilize.
Retarges one shield.
I'm, like, looking at the stuff I have.
I just don't have ammo.
That's, like, my biggest issue.
I need ammo really badly.
Lab equipment.
I don't even know what to actually get rid of.
Oh, man.
I'm just...
I guess I'll pistol.
I guess I'm pistoning.
I don't know.
So, they're 547.
Where the fuck?
Yeah, like...
Well, I assume that everybody else has already...
Everyone has enough ammo.
Fuck it.
You know what?
I'm gonna use my last recharge.
I don't really care.
Like, I just...
I need to be full HP anyway.
I don't know how I feel about this particular...
Um...
Character.
Woo!
I missed!
It's okay.
We all missed.
And then there's, like, stat...
Okay, let me see if I can actually...
I'll grab this, I guess?
We're still there.
Where's our boy?
I don't understand what...
What that sound effect means.
I...
When he does, like...
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh, other people are gonna be here.
Where's extraction shit?
This is bad, because I don't have actual...
Bullets.
I have one...
Wait, he's doing actual objective.
What is that?
What are you doing?
Storage data.
Oh my god, did I actually get...
Oh my god, I need ammo.
Please, for the love of god, give me ammo.
What the fuck does this mean?
Come on.
I'm hacking?
Oh!
I failed my hack?
I...
Bum, bum, bum.
I don't know what they're doing.
I'm just...
I'm following along the ride.
What the fuck?
All right.
Do you have ammo?
Guys, none of them have ammo.
Me and my one bullet.
Let's go!
Well, I just have millet.
Boom.
Wow!
Oh yeah, I can do that too.
But I...
No!
I don't have...
No, I don't have ammo!
Oh no.
Oh, this is bad.
Bro!
Bro, don't be stupid!
Don't be stupid!
What are you doing?
Oh my god!
It worked?
I have to just melee.
That's all I have.
Wait, where is he?
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
I don't...
No one can seek or deploy.
Jesus Christ.
All right, this is bad.
I don't have ammo.
I literally don't have ammo.
This is so bad.
I don't have ammo.
I...
Oh, please.
There has to be something with ammo!
Oh my god!
I have nothing!
Get me out!
Let me out of here!
Oh my god.
I wanna leave, but my team doesn't wanna leave!
Let me leave!
Jesus Christ, I'm fucking...
Oh my god.
Guys, we should leave.
Guys, why is my teammates still here?
Why is my teammates still trying to do something here?
Let me out of here!
I don't have another grenade!
Wait!
Guys, I nearly... This is cosmetic!
My gun is actual cosmetic right now!
Like, I have a knife!
I guess I'll just use that!
Oh my god, wait.
Does this have ammo in it?
Does this...
Guys, JK!
I have another pistol!
I have...
Guys, please!
I don't wanna be here anymore!
Fucking let's go!
Oh my god.
Guys, remember when I have, like, cosmetic?
I have cosmetic guns!
Okay.
You see us?
Okay, I'm looking.
Let's leave.
Let's go.
Guys, please, you do not need this loot.
Please.
What if I yoink?
Let's just leave.
I'm going.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm looking at the map.
How do I...
Intercept?
Is this the interception thing?
Okay.
Is there an interception thing right here?
Whoa!
Wait, I want that.
Where do I put it on my thing?
I'm taking that.
That's 540 mule right there.
Whoa!
That's a lot of mule right there.
I'm fucking rich!
With zero bullets!
Oh my god!
Money, money, money.
Must be funny.
In a rich man's world.
If we can leave.
Alright.
Ping.
Okay, intercept.
U.S.
Where are y'all?
The excru...
Where the fuck is the...
How do I get out?
How?
Guys!
Is this the...
Is this, right?
What's the thing to get...
Why are you looking at me like that?
Why?
I'm trying to figure out the map!
Okay.
Is this, right?
Guys.
We should go.
I wanna leave.
I really wanna leave, guys.
We should go.
Alright.
Where is it on my map?
Self relay...
Wait, does it not show up on my map?
Let's see.
View more.
I wanna go.
Oh, wait.
Let's go, crew.
Let's go here.
Alright.
I'm going.
There it is.
Come on, guys.
Can't be here forever.
Come on!
Let's go.
Let's go, everyone.
Hey, guys.
Let's...
Let's fucking go.
Like, we've been here in this one area for 20 years.
I'm ready to move on.
So ready to move on.
I've had it with this team.
Oh, shit.
I don't have bullets to fight this.
Alright.
Prepare for increased hostile action.
What do you mean increased...
Why is it so far?
Holy fuck!
It's like...
An actual traveling.
It's actually so fucking far.
Oh my god.
How do I ask for bullets?
I don't even know.
At least he's listening to me.
Alright.
Damn it.
Is that guy okay?
I don't know if he's okay.
He'll be fine.
Like, my mission right now is to actually, like...
Grab some bullets somewhere.
There's no way there's no bullets anywhere.
Like, I refuse to believe that...
Nobody is carrying any ammo.
Oh my god.
We have ten minutes.
Guys, please.
Okay.
We're so close.
I...
I need to know.
There has to be a minimap.
I can't be fucking pressing M the entire time.
If I die...
I deserve it.
My team and I have been, like, stuck here for 20 years.
Like...
If I die, it's, like, heavily deserved.
All right.
Oh, she's dead.
Do we leave her to die?
Do we leave her?
Um...
You're too far gone, buddy.
Sorry, man.
You're too...
You did not...
You should have followed us.
You should have fucking followed us.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I wanna go through this, cause it's, like, heavily guarded and everything.
It's not my fault.
Oh, man.
Is that, like...
How we get through this?
Holy shit.
Sorry, buddy.
You should have followed.
Wait...
There's people in here.
Okay, we can't break that.
I'm a little worried.
Where's my teammate?
Okay.
He has an actual gun.
I'm a little worried.
All right.
Bullets.
Oh my god!
I...
I have real guns!
Okay.
Goodbye, Gigaflux.
Goodbye.
Eliminated.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Real gun, though.
Oh shit!
Here we go.
It's fine.
No more real gun, though.
All right.
Oh my god.
Swap, please.
So I can shoot a real gun.
I take anything I can get.
All right.
Let's see.
North Relay.
All right.
There we go.
Let's go.
All right.
Bro, my teammate's 80 miles away.
She died so far.
I...
There's no hope for her.
Like, we have to leave.
We have to fucking leave.
Like, I'm the only one that's willing to fucking leave.
If anything, I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get absolutely, like, get my shit kicked in.
By, like, whatever random team is also at the extraction point.
Like...
I feel like...
I feel like there's some...
Another team...
There's definitely another team there.
There...
Oh my god.
There is definitely another team on that Relay right now.
This is...
I don't have ammo for a fight.
I will not be surprised if there is a team right there.
There's no way it's safe.
I'm just gonna use this just in case.
I don't...
Okay, nice.
Alright, we're safe.
We're safe.
We can actually leave.
We're so safe.
There we go.
Oh.
Okay.
I don't have real guns, so...
Um...
There we go.
Go up.
Alright.
I don't have ammo.
I don't have ammo, I don't have ammo.
So this is the best I can do.
So I actually don't have ammo.
I don't have ammo.
Oh my god, please!
No, how did you die?
Are you fucking kidding me?
No way.
There's no way.
There's no way!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, man!
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god!
It's so close!
Did I get it through?
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, man!
I had to just crawl!
I just crawl!
You can make it!
You can make it, buddy!
Just keep crawling!
Buddy, I had to get out!
I had to go away!
I won!
I did it!
I can't believe that!
No!
I lived!
I lived on straight up ditches!
Someone had to live to tell the tale!
I had to live!
Look at all this cool gear I got!
Sean, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome!
At what cost!
Look!
I ran out of ammo!
I'm sorry!
I did my best!
I ran out of ammo!
It's not my fault!
I swear!
I just don't have the ammo left!
Me and Doki made out like a bandit 07, buddy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
That's cool stuff, though!
It wasn't worth it!
It's not my... I just... I didn't have bullets!
I had to get out!
That's so fun, because this guy, like, protected me and everything!
I...
Oh, man!
I don't know if I want to queue up right away!
I don't know if I get that guy!
You were a cold piece, Doki, and I respected!
Usagi, thank you with the super chat!
Thank you!
Don't feel sorry, Doki!
That was peak extraction shooter behavior!
Candy, thank you with the super chat!
Thank you!
Look, I tried my best, guys!
I tried... I tried so hard to protect him, okay?
I swear to God!
I tried so hard to save this man's life!
I swear!
Alright!
I don't know what to... I guess I'll... I'll vault this?
I'll vault this one!
This looked good!
This looked, like, a decent...
Um...
The action shooters are not...
What do you mean?!
I did the best I could!
In that situation!
I'm not doing you cow!
Look, I'm trying...
I'm trying to look through everything, guys!
I'm not trying to look through my...
I'm trying to look through all my equipment to see what I get to keep and what I should sell, guys!
I'm making sure...
Um...
Alright...
He is disappointed!
How do you know?!
You don't know that!
Yeah, he died, so I...
Guys, we needed one person to live!
Okay?
We needed at least one person to live!
And I, unfortunately, had to be that person!
Um...
It was...
A...
Such a hard sacrifice!
Okay?
I...
It was a sacrifice I had to make...
To...
Let's see...
It was...
It was a hard sacrifice!
But like...
Someone's gotta do it!
Uh...
You think I enjoyed leaving him out to die?
You think I enjoyed that!
Guys!
I tried so hard!
Okay, I do not need... I don't know.
I feel like this stuff might be in my actual quick save.
Okay, removes.
Okay, this one I can sell.
I don't care about that.
I'll sell this.
Okay, removes.
I think I don't really need that.
I haven't had the hazardous thing.
Advanced remain, I don't want to sell is lost upon reload.
I don't have a gun.
That's for this, unfortunately.
So, uh... This is better?
Clown quest.
I'll vault this, actually.
Yeah, I'll vault it.
Uh... What do you mean he's in my chat?
I don't see him.
If he... Oh.
Oh, wait, I do.
Oh, man.
Look at all this stuff I managed to secure in my extraction.
Guys, look at...
Wow.
Man, it feels good to be able to get out.
Feels so good.
Alright, I think I'll vault this, actually.
And then... I don't know.
I feel like I should keep this.
But I have nothing that goes on it.
I don't think so.
Yeah.
I have nothing that goes on it, so I'll...
Keep it for now.
Okay, what can I do?
Location of nearby hostile when pinged by... You are not going to receive a warning.
After breaking a comment, you lay leap.
Okay.
Yeah, that's alright.
Um... How much money do I have?
Um... Alright.
There's my vault.
Look at all these cool things in my vault, guys.
Whoa.
Damn.
Okay.
I need to, like, stack this, though.
Uh... Wait, where did my other ammo go?
Um... I'll put 120.
Okay, nice.
Wait.
Actually, I'll take... I'll take that.
I'll actually have ammo now.
Guys, I have ammo for real now.
I actually have ammo now.
Okay.
And I'll grab shields.
I'll put this away.
All right.
Guys, look.
I have ammo now.
Guys, isn't that great?
I actually have bullets.
All right.
All right, guys.
You know what?
I think I do like the fact...
Oh, I can buy more ammo.
How much money do I have?
Uh... Wait, does it say how much money I have?
Okay.
I have a thousand.
Okay, this is enough ammo.
I think this is enough.
Actually, I'll buy more.
Let's just buy more just in case.
Because I feel like I'll always need more.
I'll...
Let's...
You know, let's full stock the ammo.
That was very rough for me.
That was incredibly rough with the lack of ammo situation.
All right.
You know what?
I enjoyed having crew fill on.
I...
I enjoy having teammates, guys.
Let's have teammates again.
Guys.
I think having teammates was...
Was the play.
I think...
I think it was good that we had teammates with us.
It was definitely the play.
Actually, let me check my loadout again.
Um...
I don't know if I should keep...
You know what?
Let's try it.
Let's...
Let's get the eight slots.
The trick to life is knowing that unless you are a Doki, you are never the main character.
Obscure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think having...
Having teammates was definitely the play.
You know?
Having...
Having like...
People I can use as meat shields.
Yeah.
You mean meat shields, right?
Both guns use the same ammo.
Yeah, but I only have...
Like...
I don't have any other guns.
I literally...
I don't even have a pistol at the moment.
I think I accidentally like...
I threw away my pistols accidentally.
Alright.
Here we go.
We have a British man in chibs.
Alright.
Can't be that bad this time, right?
Like this time, things won't be that bad.
Things will be fine this time.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Give me a Terran's key for this.
We'll get this gun.
Alright.
Oh my god.
These guys have definitely played already.
They knew...
They knew instantly where to go.
I was confused.
No, I didn't manage my sprint.
Not the one.
Bro, these guys instantly knew what to do.
I'm still learning at the moment.
I'm like still confused.
Like, where are my teammates?
Where did they go?
Where did they all go?
Hello.
Alright.
Alright, they definitely know how to...
These guys actually know how to shoot their guns too.
Which is great.
Whoa!
Yoink, yoink, yoink.
Oh my god.
That's a shotgun.
Yoink.
Wait, do I have ammo for a shotgun?
I do not.
Wait, where are I...
Where's the rest of my team?
I did it.
Let's see.
Yoink, yoink, yoink, yoink.
I have full inventory now.
Wait, what's this?
Decoding?
Yay!
Wait, there's ammo in that locker?
This one?
Oh, there was!
Okay, we don't...
We have too much shield charge.
We can get rid of that.
Alright, nice.
I want to try my shotgun out.
Alright.
Hello, guys.
I still don't understand the decoding shit, so...
I'm still a little confused, but I have spirit.
I have spirit.
Axis denied.
Yay!
I have spirit, though.
Bum, bum, bum.
A little battery.
I feel like I should get rid of someone.
Oh, wait.
This is $60.
Like, some of these things, I don't understand.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Is he fat?
Is he okay?
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
My mouse hit the left click accidentally.
Don't worry.
I got it.
I got spirit.
Yay!
Survey tool?
Wait.
That's valuable.
I don't need this.
Nice.
I don't know what it is, but it says valuable.
Where's my teammate?
Look, the Brit, where are you going?
What?
Wait, what?
I came from here.
Oh, I can go out, but I can't go in with it.
Oh.
Whoa!
Wait, this gun's better.
Wait.
And I'll take this.
Uh, heavy rounds?
What do I not need?
Alright, nice.
I have cool guns now.
Guys, look.
Look at my cool gun.
No, it's okay, guys.
Don't worry.
It'll be fine.
I have two cool guns, though.
But look at these sick guns that I have.
It's fine.
I have actual players.
Not that I'm saying Solar was not a real player.
I'm just saying that, like, not two real players.
I have two real players.
That's different instead of one.
Instead of one real player, I have two.
Oh, shit.
Wait, this gun is- this gun is crazy.
Look at that!
Look, this guy instantly went high ground.
Guys, this guy, he knows what's up.
He instantly went high ground.
That's a gamer right there.
All right, let's see.
I don't have any- a lot of stuff.
I'm, like, a little- Simple recall window closes in 20 minutes.
Okay.
Oh, there's food.
There's samples.
Whoa!
Wait a minute.
I want that.
What can I get rid of, though?
Wait, I want that.
That's $540.
Holy shit.
Wait.
High zoom optic?
Does that work for anything I have?
I don't think so.
That shit looks nice.
It's purple.
That means it's good.
Where's my wrist?
Wait, are these all the good shit?
Oh, they are.
Guys, I'm, like- I'm really bad at the looting part of an extraction chain.
Guys, is it noticeable that I'm- I'm, like, really confused when it comes to looting?
Is- You think it's noticeable?
Oh, was it actually blinking on my gun?
They, like- Oh, they took it.
They already took it, guys.
I couldn't- For some reason, it wouldn't let me- It wouldn't let me take it.
Oh, data card.
Wait, where did my team go?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Guys, please.
Alright.
Oh my god, these guys, like, take- These guys actually know what they're doing.
They're taking high ground and everything.
Guys.
Just fall damage, but it's, like, 1 HP.
Oh, it was highlighted in white?
Oh, that's fine.
It's fine.
I don't need it.
I believe in my team.
Try to put a square in.
What?
It goes in the triangle hole.
Does it not?
I thought he goes in the triangle.
I haven't seen, like, real players yet.
Oh.
Is there a real player over there?
Don't worry, I believe in us.
I have to, like- I hate stamina management.
I'm so bad at it.
Oh, wait.
There's people fighting already.
Wait, there's people wanting to extract here.
No, no, there's actual players.
Because you can hear a fight.
There's people actually extracting.
Wait, there's people here, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
I mean, I could press Q.
I don't know if they hear me, though.
There's two over there.
Oh, no.
Luke the Brit.
He got fully eliminated.
Oh, no.
No, buddy.
Get out of here.
I'm sorry, buddy.
Oh, no.
Luka.
The Brit.
All right, look at the good shit, though.
Look at the good shit.
Don't worry, Luka.
We got you.
Look at all the good shit he has.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Yoink.
Yoink, yoink, yoink.
All right, nice.
What does he have?
Whoa.
I don't know what all of these are.
But they look good.
I have no idea.
Um, I don't know.
I'm just like, I don't know.
They look good, though.
No.
Um, oh, my God.
This guy had...
What?
This guy had everything.
He's lost to carry more items?
What the fuck?
This guy instantly took it.
Oh, he had, like, shit guns, though.
A little.
15 minutes until signal lost.
Should we, like, leave?
Who are these people, anyway?
WSTR?
No name.
Oh, they left.
So we'll never know who his name was.
This guy is still...
This guy is still here.
He's still spectating.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
He's gone.
Wait, what are we doing?
Why are we all just hiding like this, guys?
What's going on?
Where are we...
Where are we hiding from?
I'm a little concerned.
What are we...
Where are we hiding from?
Oh.
There's, like, people now.
I've got spirit, though.
Can we leave?
Damn, what?
Oh.
Triggering exfil.
Oh, exfil.
Don't worry.
I've got spirit.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I always got the spirit.
Alright, nice.
Wait, where's the exfil?
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, it's right here.
Alright, how long?
30 seconds.
Don't worry, chips.
I believe.
I'm gonna keep my stuff.
Don't worry.
Alright, nice.
Look at that!
See?
I just needed better teeth.
Please.
We all live.
Look at that!
I'm just saying, it wasn't me.
I did it, bro.
I'm gonna say that we all live there.
They died for you, Toki.
Well, they didn't have to die for me.
Yay!
We're all alive!
We did it!
They were new too!
My teammates were also new!
We did it.
I actually really like the gun I had.
My report... Oh my god, we fought real people too!
Yeah, we're better.
We're actually better.
We fought real people.
Does it tell me who I killed?
I wish it does.
I wish it tells me who I killed.
Lady Doki Birdhouse Parquat does it again.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, I completed some missions.
I did.
Claim reward.
Lore time!
You have reached the final step of your reorientation.
I must now draw attention to the considerable financial investment your replacement shells represent.
When you experience death, cyber acne...
How is this game?
It's an extraction shooter.
That's really how I could explain it.
Like, it's...
I'll just say it's no different than the other extraction shooters I've played.
I'm just very confused.
The biggest issue I have right now is that...
The only issue I have right now is that...
The items are very confusing because they're all their own unique things.
Like, it's not, you know...
I guess in Tarkov, you can sort of tell what's what because it's based off of real life stuff.
But in Marathon, they all have their own unique names and everything.
So I don't know the looting system for this.
I'm so fucking confused when I'm looting.
I'm...
I'm like...
Like, you have to actually learn...
You have to learn, um, what your loot is.
So...
I don't know what the fuck I'm looting.
I actually...
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
Alright.
I really like the repeater.
This...
This gun is really good.
And I'm scared I'm gonna lose it.
I love it a lot and I'm scared that I'll lose this gun.
What's on this?
Okay, um...
I'm gonna keep that.
Oracle Lens.
Oh, I don't have it for this.
Um...
This does...
This ammo...
And heavy.
Um...
Let's take this...
We don't need that much ammo for this gun in particular, I feel.
Uh...
And then move to vault.
Yeah.
Yeah, I...
This is a really good gun and I feel like...
You know what?
Fuck it, it's alpha.
It doesn't matter.
Um...
What ammo?
It doesn't need this.
It doesn't need that.
It just needs these three.
Okay.
I...
Won't be surprised.
Your knife for heavy.
Brief...
Okay, I'm gonna put this away.
Your base shields.
If feeding anyone grabs a stacking bullets to your agility.
We don't need that.
Hand grenade.
All implants.
Alright.
I guess...
We'll do...
We'll do one more.
And I think I know what this game is about.
Hahaha.
No, let's try the Dire Marsh.
What's the difference?
There's nothing.
Oh, it's just...
Area is different.
Let's try this.
Alright.
Ready up.
Ooh, I have some really good equipment.
Haha.
Let's go.
Cast away your gear fear.
I know.
I'm so scared of losing my gear, guys.
Uh...
Simple Minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki really putting the me in team the stream.
I'm starting to think those wins in Marvel Reivals weren't all skill.
Thank you for the super chat.
Simple Minded.
Thank you.
Um...
Yeah, I...
So far...
I just...
I just think this...
It just feels like an extraction shooter.
So...
Uh...
So, like...
Um...
I...
Really...
That...
It's how I feel about most extraction shooters.
And...
To me...
Extraction shooters all feel the same.
For me.
Uh...
So...
I don't really have much other opinion other than...
I'm just playing extraction shooter.
Hahaha.
Um...
I am getting like...
I do...
I'm getting really confused with the type of gear...
That I have.
And what I'm trying to loot.
I do like the guns.
The guns are fun.
Cause they're not like regular...
I guess they're like...
Based off of destiny guns too.
So...
Like...
You know...
I think like...
What Bungie does really well...
Is just making cool guns.
So...
Uh...
So like...
That's fun.
I get the gun...
Guns are fun.
But...
Um...
Uh...
The ability...
The one...
The one I'm using right now...
I do like the person I'm using for the abilities.
It's cause you don't read.
There's also that.
Okay.
Alright guys.
We have Popsicle Liquor.
And...
Telly.
I don't know how great they...
These guys are.
But I...
I think they have spirit.
I...
They seem like...
They have...
The spirit...
For this game.
They have spirit.
Just like me.
You have spirit.
Yes you do.
What?
How about you?
Alright.
Let's see.
Ooh.
Health.
Don't really need health though.
To be fair.
Ooh.
I hear gunshots though.
I'm a little scared.
I'm a little spooked out.
Oh.
There's someone's been here.
Cause the door is open.
Wait.
What?
Telly.
How?
What the fuck?
Telly.
Who's shooting at you?
Buddy?
What?
Oh no.
Telly.
You have too much spirit.
He's just a regular guy.
Telly has too much spirit, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
Telly.
You have too much spirit.
But I got you.
You died to an NPC.
So that's a little awkward.
Oh man.
Guys.
I don't feel good about this team.
Maybe I should just extract now.
Maybe I should just leave.
Right now.
I'm tempted to actually just go.
I don't feel safe with this team.
I think we're that team that's gonna get absolutely destroyed later.
Alright.
Let's go.
Give them a chance.
Guys.
I have such a cool gun.
Let's go.
I have...
I'm never gonna use again.
Alright.
Let's see.
Extraction so far.
Which is a little concerning.
I'm a little concerned now about my team after my guy died to an NPC.
There we go.
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
Guys.
Please.
Shoot him.
I cannot be the only one shooting him.
I...
I could not have been the only one shooting that guy.
Please.
I swear to God.
I'm not.
I...
I was...
I felt like I was the only one shooting him.
I...
Bro, Ian!
Telly!
Did you not bring any heals on you?
How much spirit do you have?
Oh my god, he has too much.
Guys, I don't think he brought his... Oh my god, buddy!
Buddy!
How did you go outside?
Get this shot, bye.
Move!
You can move!
Why didn't you move?
Tell me!
Get out of here!
How did you get out for access?
How...
You died of him?
Buddy.
Oh my god.
I'm going to the extraction.
I am not... I'm not... I don't trust any of my...
I'm leaving.
I'm going to extraction, buddy.
Oh, there's people fighting over there, though.
Let's go.
Oh my god, the fuck is that?
There we go.
Alright, we're going.
We're going.
You don't deserve loot after that.
We're leaving.
Oh my god.
We'll grab loot on the way to go there.
Oh...
There's people fighting there.
There's real people over there.
I don't think...
No!
Do not...
Oh my god!
Do not signal the real people!
Oh no.
Oh no, the real people know we're here, too.
There we go.
That was actually, like...
A tanky guy.
Let's see an increase.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, nice.
Alright.
He's saying no real people that we're here.
So, like...
I'm a little sad.
We need all that.
We need the shield, so...
I'm a little sad and a little worried.
Because now real people know we're here.
There we go.
I'll get these guys out.
I don't trust my team no more.
I...
I don't trust...
There are more babies than me.
Why is there so...
Why is it so far?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Why is he extracted so far?
Look, after what I saw happen to Telly, I...
I can't trust anybody anymore.
I live with zero trust.
Oh, there's people in front of me.
I hear them.
Oh my god.
Okay, popsicle liquor looks like...
He has more than just spirit.
So the way he is ADing...
I believe in him.
Telly, on the other hand...
Is a little special...
Is our special little guy.
I saw him strafing while he was aiming.
So like...
He's somebody I can believe in.
I'm like really...
Are you down again?
Buddy!
Oh no.
How are you down again?
Where are you down?
Oh wait, this is a real person.
This is actually a real person.
Actually.
Okay.
They're real.
So we have to be careful.
Because that was a cloak.
Okay.
I'm scanning from here.
There we go.
Is that real?
No, actually.
He was...
Oh no.
It was an AI.
I forgot.
AIs can cloak too.
Never mind.
JK.
He wasn't real.
Thank god.
He wasn't real, guys.
He was AI.
It freaked me out.
He started cloaking.
I wasn't ready.
Guys.
I wasn't ready when these...
We're leaving Telly.
He started cloaking.
It was wrong.
Oh my god.
I need like shields.
I want to...
I'm going to head to...
I'm heading to extraction.
I don't care.
We don't need loot anyway.
I...
Well, I need shields.
But like...
That's fine.
I need shields here.
I'll grab the credits.
Alright.
This guy can sort of...
Vaguely aim.
Which is good.
Alright.
Tokyo.
You do not miss Telly.
You don't even know this person.
How do you miss somebody you don't even know?
Okay.
I don't have...
The only issue is that I don't have my scan anymore.
Okay.
I'll steal the money.
Yoink.
My money now.
Grab that.
I'll leave him the scraps.
It's his fault for being slow as fuck.
Okay.
We're not close.
But I like to believe we're almost there.
He was all of us.
If you were Telly...
Oh my god.
Like, if that's how you play...
You might need to give Alpha access to somebody else.
Can I climb up here?
No, I can't.
Alright.
Okay.
We have to go from this side.
It's like I'm still here.
Or...
I'm like a little worried that like...
A team's gonna be like...
Ooga booga booga.
Like, that's what's worrying me right now.
How the fuck do I have to walk across this?
Oh my god.
Alright.
My...
Guys, we all saw how Telly played.
Guys, we all saw it.
I need shields so badly.
I hate...
I hate stamina management.
I hate it so much.
Oh my god.
I don't like this.
I don't like the sound I'm hearing.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're almost there.
Wait, is it protected?
No, it's not.
Okay.
That's good.
I miss my old crew.
Guys.
Alright.
I miss them.
I miss them so much.
They...
They stood on high ground.
I...
I miss them so much.
They stood on high ground, guys.
That's already, like, such an upgrade.
They know how to stand on high ground.
Alright.
I have access to this.
Maybe I can open it.
Nope.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We can do this, guys.
Do it.
Nice.
There we go.
We're five.
We're so safe.
We're so safe, guys.
Where is...
Popsicle?
Oh, there he is.
Look at that.
I get to keep my stuff, too.
You know what?
I feel so confident.
I do this.
There we go.
See?
We're so safe.
We just gotta live for 30 more seconds.
Go!
Go get your loot!
I got all the stuff I need!
Oh, wait.
There he is.
There we go.
See?
Don't ever say I never helped.
Nice.
You know what?
I feel so safe.
I'm putting this down.
Oh, man.
It would be a shame if he dies right here.
Goodbye, popsicle liquor.
Goodbye.
If you die, you die.
I was not guiding anybody.
I
got him!
That's why...
Why did he leave?
That was not my fault.
He could have left with me.
He could have stood.
How is that my fault?
He didn't go back.
He's getting lost.
He didn't go to the extraction point.
I was literally waiting.
He missed the telephone point.
He'll make it, guys.
It would be funny if a team rolled up right now.
It would be very funny.
It would be pure cinema if that happened.
You know what?
Three out of three.
I lived.
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm going back to Hong Kong this weekend.
Gonna eat all the curry fish balls.
French toast.
Ball about egg tarts.
Egg waffles.
And cheap 7-Eleven Suma in your name.
Thank you.
It was super chat.
We have a good time.
Look.
See?
He got out.
He got out, guys.
We did it.
Let's go.
Tell me what I'm saying.
Look at that.
We fucking did it, guys.
We're competent people.
Look at that.
All right.
See?
We don't talk about what happened to Tully.
But me and Popsicle Liquor, we survived.
We fucking survived, guys.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, I got to claim another thing.
Claim reward.
Congratulations, runner.
Yeah.
That's me.
And have proven yourself fully functional.
Two mega corporations have requested access to a partition of your neural interface.
Your actions on Tazeti piqued their interest.
The people who matter got out.
Guys, that's all that matters.
Yeah, we don't...
Who's telling?
Well, that's why they don't matter no more.
People are able to fulfill their priority contracts.
They may come to feel you can be relied on for more...
Yay, I'm reliable.
But most of these megacorps may align with yours or run counter to your motivations.
You are free to engage with them as you see fit.
Cyber Acme will continue to provide you with support as we are invested in your success.
You can rely on Cyber Acme to be...
He said I'm reliable.
...the journey takes you across Tau Ceti and beyond.
All right, nice.
I do the lore for you guys.
I know some of you guys are into the lore.
You have completed requirements to rank up.
Oh, I ranked up!
Nice!
What do I get?
Ranking up.
Why won't you let me claim?
Oh, I have to press F.
Agents from reach out with employment offers.
Visit each faction to speak with their respective agents and accept it.
Okay.
So, upgrades.
You have earned one rank...
Wait, what is this?
For a purchase with credits.
Oh, I can buy...
I can buy...
Grenades now.
Nice.
And then...
Now there's cores.
Oh!
Now you have to up...
Okay.
Oh, that's interesting.
You have to, like, upgrade your own backpack without...
So, like...
You have to loot...
You have to loot these items to get, like, a permanent upgrade.
And stuff.
Yeah.
I get it.
Why did I get frag grenades?
I should have got bag space.
Okay.
So, you have to...
I'll show you guys.
You have to, like...
Get specific loot.
So that you can, like, get permanent upgrades on your character.
So, like, you know, there's, like, cores.
Standard cores.
And there's, like, bag upgrades.
And then grenades.
I can finally have grenades.
And then there's, like, gadgets.
I don't know what the gadgets are.
But there's stuff like that.
And I guess now that I...
Let's see.
Earn a reputation.
Can I, like, work...
And then I can work for other agencies.
I'm a free agency now.
I'm a free agent.
Essentially everywhere.
I am
God's furnishings.
I'm an independent runner.
I work for no corporations.
I'm a free agent.
We need to stick in the original colony.
Mishkaloric exists to feed, clothe, and supply humanity with its most basic...
The lore...
The lore mystic is very interesting.
Because it feels very dystopian.
I think that's the proper word to describe it.
I feel like I'm in a dystopia right now.
I'm an indie runner.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I can work for...
Oh, I can...
Like, I can choose which company...
Um...
I want to work for.
So there's Traxxus, too.
Where...
There's a lion in there.
Wait, I got to talk to a lion?
Is this Aslan?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
I don't...
Oh, I don't like her.
Oh my gosh.
I...
I don't like her.
Oh, I feel so uncomfortable right now.
I am...
I actually feel incredibly uncomfortable.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Traxxus, author of the masterminds, is the interplanetary economic leader across every major industrial category.
I...
Oh my god.
This is uncannily...
This is actually uncanny valley right now.
I am so uncomfortable.
I am...
Applicants may not be considered Traxxus employees.
As non-corporate...
I am not okay.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Yeah, she feels very uncanny valley.
Like, the way...
Oh, with the lion, too?
Oh, I...
Oh my god.
Ha ha ha ha.
I don't know how I feel about her.
Ha ha ha.
All right.
I mean, the quester...
Download geological survey.
Yeah, it's very creepy for sure.
Uh...
I feel like...
I sort of got every...
I don't want to like...
I think like the other characters...
I think like Blackbird...
I know I just...
I use Locust and Blackbird.
But reading like...
The...
Um...
Reading like...
The...
The abilities for the other characters...
I feel like...
Blackbird is definitely the strongest in a team environment.
Like the fucking...
Um...
The fucking like...
Tracker drone and...
The Echo Pulse...
Was so good for me.
For when I'm like in a team fight.
And...
Like this...
Blackbird was like really fun to play.
But...
Um...
I know that all the people that kept dying...
Were on glitch.
Yeah.
Telly was on glitch.
And then...
What was it?
The...
The first guy...
On our team...
Was Sol...
Solar or whatever.
Um...
That...
They...
They both died.
All I'm saying...
And was not with us...
In the...
In the extraction.
So that's all I'm saying.
Every...
All the characters...
All the players that I had...
The teammates that I had...
They were on glitch.
Did not make it.
Um...
And you know...
What had a hundred percent...
Uh...
Extraction rate?
Blackbird.
Locust is like...
Seems like a tank.
He's like a good tank player.
I've...
I've seen one of their guys...
Use void.
But like...
I wasn't very impressed...
With the void thing.
Uh...
The void abilities...
Because of the smoke screen.
Um...
And...
I didn't see any smoke screen abilities.
We saw one...
One of our teammates...
Um...
On void.
But yeah...
I think Blackbird was definitely my favorite character.
Um...
Out of all of them.
I mean...
I did only use two characters...
But I saw a lot of teammates die on glitch.
So I know that she's shit.
Um...
Let's see...
Yeah...
I think...
I have enough intel on this game.
Will I play this again?
Most likely not.
I might try it out on release.
I don't think I'll try the beta.
I don't think I'll try the beta for it.
But I might try the release of Marathon...
To see what they change.
But...
Or I get paid to.
Or I get sponsored.
So far, I'm not like incredibly impressed.
Only because it just feels like an extraction shooter to me.
I think the gunplay is really fun.
Um...
No, this was not sponsored.
I literally just got a...
I got a free code.
So like...
Um...
It wasn't sponsored or anything.
They just sent me a code.
And they like invited...
And I wanted to check it out.
I wanted to check it out.
And see how it feels like.
I think maybe if I have people to play with...
It'd definitely be more fun.
If I have like my...
If I'm playing with friends and stuff.
It could be more fun.
Because you're coordinated.
But even going in with randoms.
It did not feel that difficult at all.
Um...
I was not happy with the stamina management.
Because it...
I feel like...
I guess like...
Later on, you're gonna...
You can get upgrades to have more stamina.
And stuff.
Um...
It feels like...
There would be...
Stamina upgrades to manage.
Uh...
And...
Other than that...
I do like the guns.
I really like the guns.
I'm not happy about the stamina management.
And...
Um...
At the moment...
We had one team fight with an actual...
Players.
But they seemed really bad.
Or...
I think my teammates were also...
Really, really good.
I think it helped a lot...
That I was like...
Bloodhound.
I guess.
Like Blackbird.
So I gave intel to the rest of my team.
And then I sent out like...
An explosive bomb.
And we like...
Killed people instantly.
We literally instantly killed the team.
So...
I feel like...
Uh...
Um...
I feel like...
The team fight we had was super easy.
Because I actually had a very good team...
That I ran with Q into.
Um...
But...
I don't think I would like to play solo in this game.
Because I feel like...
With the abilities in general...
It might be actual hell.
Like...
So...
Yeah.
And the fact that, you know...
People are figuring out how to play this game.
It is in alpha right now.
Um...
So people are still...
People are still trying to figure out this game.
And people haven't unlocked like all the tech yet.
So like...
Honestly, it's basically like...
Who can...
Everyone is just out aiming the other.
So like...
Luckily...
Like...
I can sort of aim.
So...
Um...
It wasn't that difficult to...
Out aim the one team fight I had.
Uh...
Um...
But...
Yeah.
Like...
Right now, it's just like...
Whoever uses their ability...
Whoever can out aim the other...
At the moment.
Um...
But yeah.
Maybe I'll try it out more off stream.
Maybe I'll actually give my friend codes to people...
Friend codes to people.
And just try it out.
But so far...
Um...
It just feels like every extraction shooter I have played so far.
And I personally am not really an extraction shooter type of person.
Like I don't play Tarkov or anything.
The gunplay feels like Destiny.
Um...
So the guns are really fun.
I know Bungie is really good at making guns.
So like making guns feel nice.
So...
I like the gunplay.
I was hitting shots.
And that's a plus for me.
Um...
But it just...
It's an extraction shooter.
If you really like Tarkov...
If you really like extraction shooters...
But you don't like the gunplay of Tarkov...
And you like gunplay from Halo and Destiny...
Then you might like this game.
But at the moment, I'm not a Tarkov person.
So it just feels like an extraction shooter I've played many times in terms of other extraction shooters that I've played.
But yeah, that's my honest opinion.
I think if I was an extraction... If I did like Tarkov, I might really like this game, I think.
Because I did enjoy using the abilities.
And I did enjoy using the abilities on Blackbird.
And I did like the guns.
So I feel like if I was into extraction shooters, I'd like this game.
So yeah, that's my opinion.
That's what I'll say about it.
And I guess that's how... I think three runs was enough.
Because it felt like if I do another run, it'd just be the same thing.
It'd just be me trying to grab loot and then trying to get out.
Because that's what it is.
I felt like it was just basically... I sort of got a gist of it after three runs.
I sort of got a gist of what the gameplay was about at that point.
And I do have another stream later today.
So... So we'll call it here.
Thank you everybody for watching.
I hope you guys enjoyed checking out Marathon and seeing what the gameplay is like.
Um... I do have another stream in... I guess like four hours.
So I'm gonna call it here.
As always everybody... Stay hydrated.
Pause check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And if you stay up for me... Head to bed.
Because... You deserve it.
I'll see you guys later tonight.
Bye everybody... I need to make the waiting room by the way.
I did not make the waiting room yet.
I was so tired.
Anyway, I'm gonna make the waiting room after the stream.
I'll see you guys later tonight.
Bye everybody.
Bye.
Wait, did I finish my... I don't even remember if I finished.
As always everybody... Stay hydrated.
Pause check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And use that for me.
Head to bed or say... Oh, I said it already.
Head to bed or go watch the stream tonight with Min.
Bye, everyone.
Bye!